right last time i saw this man i was
making scrambled eggs
whilst crying my bloody eyes out it has
to be one of the spiciest days of my
life
and honestly i wake up some morning
still sweating with over 76 million
views
it's become legendary but tonight it's
time for the hottest challenge
yet and in order to do this trust me i
need my man back
the incredible the feisty the tenacious
the man with the plastic palette
please welcome back the incredible sean
evans sean
gordon gordon it is so good to see you
my man thank you so much for that
intro i am so happy to have you back for
another round here
uh mate when you sat me in that chair
uh first of all i'd like to apologize
because the chair looked like a bloody
swimming pool
underneath my ass within like 60 minutes
everywhere i go i'm asked about bloody
sean
evans and is he eating the same
hot sauce that you're eating so just
confirm
for the 76 million that saw that you are
eating the same sauce you're not lying
are you
every single time and you know i'm more
than happy to switch the paddle
with our guests right before we go you
know anything that i can just
stake my integrity on it is that every
time
a guest has gone through the hot ones
gauntlet i've gone through it right
along with them
yes but you said to me gordon i feel
like the albatross has been lifted
and i've got this weight off my neck and
now i can get on with my show and
congrats on the seasons and the
syndicated show but guess what i did
that studio i
lost nearly 15 pounds in weight so i
just
understood that if you want to go on a
crash course and you want to lose weight
eat sean evans hot wings because within
60 minutes
the pounds are gonna drop man for days
after tana kept on looking at my
trousers and said
what are you doing you're spending more
time in the loo than you are with me
it's that source
it burns and burns and burns
and you know what and you know what
today it's kind of a crazy ride you know
like last time you did the show
we do 10 wings 10 saucers and it ends up
in a crazy place
here the good news is we're only doing
five wings today so it might seem like
we're taking our foot off the gas a
little bit
but we are not because the ramp up here
is extreme
over here in the middle we have the
brain burner
we have the eye of the scorpion we have
hot ones
apollo these are three extreme super
hots
the eye of the scorpion with trinidad
scorpions apollo
is just from the mad scientist brain of
smoking ed curry
and we fed him off in kind of a easy
zone on the first two but after that
it is crazy so we are putting on a show
for the people today
uh i had like
lumps and bumps on my pallets for like
days on end
my chefs are saying gordon if you ever
go on the hot ones again
and we lose our third missionary star i
honestly i'm gonna kick you up the ass
so i know there's only five sources but
just go
easy on the old man please i will i will
try i will try and if you guys were to
lose the michelin star i wouldn't be
able to sleep i would take that
personally i would feel like it were my
fault so not today gordon i'm going to
take good care of you
and we'll start with the classic which
is this
important the other one the classic with
the red lady yes that one there
so this is our first one it's it's just
the first sauce that we use
in the in the show as you remember nice
and easy not too bad here to start us
off
yes okay um
did you check out those wings your
bugger they don't look like my
granddad's toes these are a proper wing
well you know what gordon ever since
you're on the show and dogged the wings
a lot of people have been complimenting
us
we've stepped up our game since uh since
you were on the show so we're doing much
better
right um if you don't mind me i've got a
quick
tip you line your tongue with cheddar
cheese
cheddar cheese stops the actual tongue
from burning
this is amazing okay
did it work
it does work but this is quite fruity so
not spicy
but it's actually quite fruity it sort
of tastes um
of a lot of tomatoes a little bit of um
almost like a sort of a nail
but it's not super hot by the way nope
just like your everyday
sort of table sauce to start us off here
so with the holiday season in full swing
you know gatherings will probably not be
as big this year but the feasts we need
to keep them in mind
as a brit who spent a lot of time in the
states
what do you see is the biggest
difference between holiday priests in
the uk
versus the holiday feasts in the u.s
i've just taken shots of um the most
amazing pepto-bismol smoothies
so i put some protein powder after
ginger
and they're like a sort of traffic light
in front of me so all nice and cool
and all jokes apart having been you know
in the u.s over the last well just under
20 years now
thanksgiving and christmas is pretty
much similar i get so frustrated when
that bird gets deep-fried um and the
vats of oil
and this thing gets wound down like
medieval days and they deep fry this
thing
there's a reason why we only eat turkey
once the year okay
and come on you know there's nothing
worse than the dry bird at christmas so
i'm a big fan of deep frying that turkey
but i like to put the butter under the
breast um
fragrant with some thyme lemon citrus um
and then
once it's cooked i like to let it rest
for as long as i cook it
but the garnishes the sprouts the
parsnips um
the only thing we don't do uh over here
is that sort of pecan pie
the sweet elements it's very similar all
the garnishes and the roast potatoes and
duck fat but
honestly i always treat thanksgiving as
a warm up for christmas
but then i'm thinking no please do not
deep fry that turkey
and then what do you see is the secret
to a great good
roast potato when i have the when i have
the sunday roast whenever i visit london
that stands out to me it's a unique item
yeah good question so the secret between
a great roast potato is like
partly sort of boiling them and then
take them
taking them out to sort of steam once
you steam them they get fluff on the
outside
and then from there they literally get
nice and crispy but they need to be
steamed
and then roasted christmas pudding
overrated or underrated oh no no it's
underrated
honestly i mean the sad news about the
christmas pudding is that you feel like
taking a two-week holiday after you've
taken a bite
but sometimes there's a lot of rum in
that thing and between you and i it's a
great way to get the kids to sleep on
christmas day a couple of mouthfuls
um they think it's a creme anglaise with
custard but i've laced it with baileys
and then two minutes later they're
faster sleek
that's the pro tip are you ready to move
on we have some
very special guests joining us for this
next wing
yes please
so this is los calientes moho
and then joining us here we have shelby
and jim
shelby of course you remember in 2013
granted a wish where she got to meet you
on the set of hell's kitchen
she has since then beaten cancer gone on
to culinary school
and now is a trained pastry chef and
then jim also
showcasing his cooking skills on the
bearded home cook
channel let's bring in shelby and jim
oh my goodness um first of all happy
holidays to you both uh
shelby you know seven years ago when i
first met you um
and understand the diagnosis what you're
faced with
i said to my three daughters i've just
met a girl that has strength beyond
belief but more importantly
um has the remarkable
sort of power to overcome this when i'm
looking at your feed
on instagram and watching the way you
post and then obviously
watching what you've done through
culinary school and now progressing
brilliantly
um let me tell you something when you
want to come and work for me
my door is open because not only do you
become a dear friend
but the talents of what you're producing
is incredible and
you know dad as a
as a father of three daughters how proud
are you
she's amazing absolutely amazing every
day in treatment and after
this kid never stops smiling she's
inspired so many people
uh i wake up every day blessed to be her
dad it's amazing
yeah shelby gorgeous how are you doing
i'm doing very well
thank you how are you yeah all good
indeed thank you it's about
7 7 30 here oscar's gone to bed and i'm
just
going to go through these wings with my
man and then
crack on for dinner so it's been a crazy
day but
um shelby what's been the
what was what was the the most important
thing that you focused on because i knew
food was important for you but
what did you what did you hold on to
getting through that treatment what was
the
the light at the end of the tunnel that
kept you going
um honestly just kind of doing what i
love doing which is putting art into
food
um like everything i do on paper i just
like how i made you that scratch board
honestly i just put that into like
baking cakes and decorating cakes and
cookies as well so i just kind of put my
art onto something edible
yeah amazing and i love that edible art
but since we last met
as you know we've opened the hell's
kitchen restaurant in vegas uh sean's
been
a few times he has his own table now
he's that famous in vegas with his
name on it they bring his napkin out
with his initials on
the table class got his initials on the
hot table for the hot host
um i'd like to invite you uh and a group
of your girlfriends to come
uh as guests uh for dinner whenever you
like
whenever you're ready uh yeah i promise
you my darling across 2021
you you you just tell me and we'll sort
it out
okay okay that's amazing that is amazing
thank you
take them up on that they treat you very
well
right i'm so excited are you ready
are you ready to get sweaty yeah so
sean sent us some sauces but he didn't
send me any wings so
uh in the in the pre-show we threw it
out there that if we could raise
a thousand dollar increments five times
i would
put them in on cookies because we have
lots of cookies so we're gonna do hot
sauce cookies
uh and right at the end as i was about
to get away with two hot sauces
taylor and meredith who have been huge
supporters of make-a-wish here in north
carolina dropped 10 grand so guess what
i'm doing all five sauces on cookies so
if i don't talk while you guys are doing
your thing
you're just going to be sweating back
here according that's amazing bought a
cocktail
i mean
[Laughter]
okay our next sauce is los calientes
rojo
if you watch the show it's it's the
halfway mark it's
it's halfway down the lineup so a little
bit of a kick
but not too crazy not too wild i
have to know how it tastes on a cookie
though that might be a first
it is really weird
yeah but what's hot
yeah oh i'm okay thank you though
wow i think there's lemon in it i also
brought my own
i don't know if i'm supposed to wipe my
backside with them or not
gordon taking down the flight of
antidote
um so now you've just kicked up a notch
that is a raw spice super hot
and uh it's very uh
it's rough right it's sort of um it
wakes you up
okay because right now in between my big
toe
and my pinky i've started to sweat which
is never a good sign
because it starts to move up shall we
i'm going to stop there but
not decent so gordon last time you're on
the show
besides all the sweating we talked about
some of these more bizarre food trends
like
spaghetti doughnuts or black burger buns
and since then
tick tock has really taken over the
world and you've kind of
turned to discovering these bizarre food
creations on that platform
and uh you know shelby i'd be curious
your thoughts on this as well
gordon shelby jim what do you
think of social media and how it
affects or changes or influences
how people cook at home yeah that's a
good question
um tick tock originally was set up to
sort of bring that level of
fun in dancing i got size 15 feet
matilda
uh our youngest daughter she's always
dancing on there so she said dad you got
to do this tick tock thing i said really
tilly
she then made me switch the light off
and jump into her clothes she jumped in
mine was slightly weird
because it didn't go down well with the
dear wife because she said what are you
doing a man of your age dressing your
daughter's clothes
however the whole excitement around tick
tock now is about having fun i think
tick tock's been a breath of fresh air
across the pandemic and more importantly
it gives a lot of hope to having some
fun especially
through dark times and you know watching
what make a wish have done in terms of
sending videos and
sort of little anecdotes there's now a
brigade sean
of t tick tock chefs out there they're
sort of
obsessed they can't cook for crap but
they edit their videos down where they
make themselves look good but
to be honest that's the editor so it's
very funny and last week
a girl uh i think she was in
boston took a rib right there on your
eyes gordon oh [ __ ]
yes she was in boston and she stuck two
rib eye steaks
inside a toaster to cook the rib eyes in
a toaster
i saw that come on
shall we you must have seen some crazy
nuts on tick tock i've actually
seen that rib eye one but honestly tic
toc has also shown people how to make
that like
whipped coffee which a lot of my friends
have made that was kind of in the
beginning of like the whole stay-at-home
order and everything everyone was making
it i was not one of those people
unfortunately but
i should have um no i am enjoying tick
tock yet because i feel like i'm the old
guy that when i like facebook everybody
goes to instagram
when i go to instagram everybody goes to
tick tock or snap or whatever else so
if you think i need to put food on tick
tock just know we're going to scare away
millions of youth
well i haven't really been cooking on
tick tock but i have
recently into a new apartment and done a
lot more home cooking than i used to do
i used to be just
straight a diet of crap service
but now i'm actually in the kitchen
doing my thing
i i have some samples uh some pictures
of some recently
cooked dishes and i'm just curious what
you guys think of each so this first one
that's up it's kind of it's seasonal
very autumn like so
this is a apple butter pork tenderloin
and then you have some roasted carrots
beets that's little uh
goat cheese milk with there with that
the sauce is like
applesauce cinnamon cream sort of thing
that i made
i have thick thick skin dude
i mean there's a great color on the pork
portion slightly tiny but
it looks like the cat's puked on the
side of the plate what is that
is that a sauce it's a sauce yeah it's a
little
little apple apple sauce little cinnamon
uh
little cream sort of situation that i
put together now you sort of stuck a uh
a dessert on the side of the pork
um promise me you won't bottle that
sauce i i
i promise you i promise you on
shelby jim do you guys have any uh
thumbs up thumbs down what do you think
so apple butter is super famous here in
north carolina we absolutely love it
would you agree
um but when you put it on a plate that
light of a color it reminds me of
something that comes out
the wrong way um thank you it looks
great
yeah pretty tasty all right let's move
on to the next one
up next this was actually my first one
like my first home-cooked meal in years
it's a
sherry glazed chicken with zucchini
and then i think those are some uh
asiago
stuffed tomatoes alongside i mean what a
donut first of all you don't put cherry
on a freaking chicken now you keep that
for your trifle your muppet
secondly the zucchini looks shocking at
least turn the pan on to get some color
i mean of all the food chats we've had
over the years you present that to me
honestly it looks like the sort of
leftovers from a frat party
not for me all right one more hopefully
i can win you over with this last one so
this is actually
this is actually this next one this is
my first attempt
at a home style fried chicken then you
have some corn
and then some green onion mashed
potatoes alongside that
okay so listen you got a great color on
the chicken there so i like that
um that corn looks like a leftover
succotash from last thanksgiving
so again come on some chili
some shallots and garlic give it some
love and and the mash
that looks like it's just been whipped
out of some bears backside
[Laughter]
oh goodness gracious i'm humble i'm
humbled i'm humbled before having you
guys
we need to spend more time in the
kitchen mr evans a hundred percent you
know
uh i'm i'm there anytime anytime
but i'm i'm working my way i'm working
my way you got to start somewhere
i'm working on it has been a lot of fun
it has been a lot of fun it's all the
people out there who are
who fear it or who are worried about it
or like oh it's so much easier to order
this sort of uh i've kind of fallen in
love with the ritual of it all with sort
of
music and chopping stuff up and
preparing the ingredients like
the whole part of the experience for me
is something that i've really fallen in
love with
good all right
i haven't done enough stalling
as we move on down
the line up
so yes
brain burner is that right
it gets pretty crazy here oh excuse me
please
man why am i burping already
that is that the brain burner
this is the brain burner this next one
and it is pretty crazy hot
it's a wild one
look at what's in there
jesus so
so this one it's a mix of scotch bonnet
peppers
carolina reaper a six-figure scoville
rating
it is like a prank gordon i can see it
in your face
jimbo i can see it in your face yeah
yeah
yeah no that's uh that's uh
that's rancid yeah
that's uh that's rough man that's uh
man that's like eating a mouthful of
bobby flays cuisine
that's gross you can still burn you
still got that you still got that dragon
fire gordon ramsay
burn there's no flavor in the chicken
wing you've just decimated any taste of
chicken you don't know
flamethrower but
through the pain through the burn
through the fire gordon ramsay i'm very
curious
you know um this year uh
you know we have people outside the
workforce but i know that the second we
can get back out in the streets the
thing that i'm looking forward to mostly
is returning to a buzzing dining room
i think yes on your world travels
if you close your eyes and think of your
most memorable food experience
what first memory that comes to mind
two secs yep
um i would have to say um something like
um cambodia we were there recently
filming and you know vietnamese
cambodian cuisine you know very little
dairy
you know the incredible broths the paste
the make out of shrimp
you know indonesia again
just incredible so
yeah i'd go for a vietnamese um because
that level of
you know humble cooking was just
exceptional especially when they do it
properly there so
um breathtaking and then the big
surprise this summer was when we went to
visit
um croatia croatia has sort of always
played
second fiddle to italy but the croatian
cuisine and the truffles
that we discovered in croatia and the
shellfish was just
exceptional so yeah croatia and vietnam
jim how you feeling after that last
sauce
i can't feel my lips my nose is running
and i'm sweating like a pig inside
yeah all of us all of us that same exact
way i've had that sauce many times
before
you never fully get used to it
after that sauce we'll try to move a
little bit quicker
towards the finish line this next one is
the eye of the scorpion
as the name would imply it has a
combination
of trinidad scorpion peppers very
very spicy brutal hot sauce
it looks like the smell
honestly it's so strong
man
chocolate chips and hot sauce there's
just something wrong about this
brutal
absolutely brutal
no no no no no no
no that was disgusting capital d
not good people discussing the difficult
here to close it out
but we're almost there we're approaching
the finish line here and
you're on the topic of spicy foods you
know obviously
as you can tell we push it to the
extreme here on hot ones
but it does seem like the palette for
spicy foods does seem to be growing
whether it's these
spicy chicken sandwiches that you see on
fast food
spicy cocktails spicy gum but one place
i don't really see it is in fine dining
gordon do you have any insight
as to why you don't see that same sort
of
spice bubble and fine dining i've had
the opportunity to take on some tasting
menu
since the show's blown up but you don't
really see spice
in the same way that you see other food
categories
yeah the idea across the fine dining
menu you donut is to entice you across
the 15 courses
so if we obliterate your palette with
spice on course number three
how the hell are you going to spend all
that money on wine enjoy an amazing
dinner
when you can't taste anything for the
next 15 courses you
bloody idiot so we have a blend of spice
that we build ourselves up and we make
things a little bit more sort of uh
you know enticing but without being too
spicy
right oh excuse me
why do we put it in dessert
yeah yeah just putting on a dessert the
the cookie spicy food situation
man we are on now the last
chicken wing level one this is
the last dab of apollo
and uh full disclosure i i accidentally
on the first wing did take a bite out of
this one just
just going from the wrong side of my
paddle here so here i am
bringing it all full circle
excuse me i got blisters on my lips
oh my god it smells like a sweet
disinfectant
[Laughter]
good way to put it
disinfectant jim going down the hatch
i'm actually really happy i'm not trying
these i'm leaving at all to him
i'm good thanks actually the guy being
dummies out here
all right jim and gordon i'd be curious
on your answer for this one because
gordon last time you were on the show
i could tell that there are certain
sauces certain wings that you weren't
really impressed with
so here we've swapped some of the old
out
and put in some of the new take in your
chef's
palette test can you tell me
which sauce here did you like the most
and then
what are some qualities that go into the
ones that you like the least
which one did you like the most
first two are pretty good i'm bleeding
again down below
are you serious out of those five no
that's not hitting my menu man is insane
the last one i had to dip inside my
pepto
bloody smoothie in order to down
and taste something um no the first one
was slightly fruity i'd take that one
again in a heartbeat but those last four
no
no no no i told you last time my nose
was running faster than
mo farah this time i've got a usain bolt
9.967
of each nostril no chance not for me
every time he do it to me jim
if i could talk i really kind of like
the second one i thought that
there's a lot of flavors and it just
kept building and building i mean it's
it's the most chunky one of them too
which i think is kind of neat because
you get those flavors in every bite if
you will
um yeah yeah that's what i got for you
uh sean seriously i mean honestly
uh i'm i'm sweating
so bad that i'm actually wearing
waterproof pants
well you know when we put on a show like
that for the people watching i just want
to say thank you for watching
please we are so close
please don't please donate if you're
watching
to make sure that we all didn't just
burn our insides
yes over here i've burned more than the
insides i said to you last time shame on
you then you made me made scrambled egg
so i'm not making any more bloody
scrambled egg but
um donations are rolling in michael's
just put two and a half grand in
very kind uh oh reaper's just putting a
hundred dollars
and then mark from the kick club has
just donated
70 grand and we're into a hundred and
ten thousand
to what jim and i sweat while you sit
there laughing you [ __ ] head off
i swear to god uh i'm gonna i'm gonna
wrap you in plym film and stick you on
the top of caesar's palace next time i
see you in vegas
all right all right as long as i can as
long as you can give me a table at
hell's kitchen i'll take you up on that
absolutely um listen sean thank you so
much
and i i'm i'm
i'm i'm touched because seven years ago
shelly when we first
shelby we first met and i saw just your
situation
and then i think about the incredible
work that make-a-wish do
and now that you've become this beacon
of hope and
joy um you spend many many christmases
uh just promise me this time next year
we won't be spending it eating
bloody hot wings again with the man okay
take care jim thank you sir
shelby a beacon of light um
stay focused and uh lots of love
sure i'm gonna get you back buddy
i'm gonna keep i'm keeping my hair on
the level i'm keeping my i'm looking out
for you gordon
i'm looking out for you really nice to
meet you
it was a lot of fun thank you mate